okay today I'm going to talk to you
about enzyme graphs these are just
simply graphs associated with enzyme
activity as a very quick recap enzymes
of biological catalysts that's something
which speeds up a rate of reaction
without being used of itself the act on
substrate molecules the substrate
molecule fits into the active site of an
enzyme in a complementary way and gets
broken down to form products so what
we're going to look at is how three
different things affect enzyme activity
and we're going to see the graph
associated with each one so the first
one we're going to look at is
temperature temperature so with each of
the graphs up the y-axis we have rate of
reaction all this means is how fast the
enzyme reaction is happening so on
the temperature graph the shape of the
graph looks very much like this it goes
up and then it comes back down again and
it gets to zero here now along the
x-axis we have temperature because at
this side of the x-axis we have a very
low temperature and quite a low rate of
reaction as we increase the temperature
we have an increase in rate of reaction
but as we keep on increasing the
temperature the rate of reaction Falls
until it's zero so why does this happen
so initially there is an increase of
rate of reaction just like in any
chemical reaction because as we heat up
these particles to substrate in the
enzyme we give them more kinetic energy
so there's going to be more collisions
between our substrate and our active
site this keeps on going until we reach
something which is called the optimum
temperature this particular temperature
optimum temperature and this particular
temperature the enzymes are working most
efficiently now in the human body
is usually around 37 degrees Celsius
however if we keep on increasing the
temperature the rate of reaction starts
to drop now the reason why this is is
due to the active site that intense heat
breaks down the active site which means
the substrate can no longer fit in
because it can't fit in anymore no more
substrate can be broken down and
therefore we will have a slower rate of
reaction this process is called
denaturing so the hotter it gets the
more and more enzymes are denatured
therefore the slower the rate of
reaction the next thing we're going to
look at is the effect of pH on rate of
reaction just like before up the y-axis
where you're going to show rate of
reaction but this time across the x-axis
we are going to show we're going to show
the pH remember pH is just the measure
of how acid or how alkaline something is
on our pH scale remember a pH of one
would be very acidic a pH of seven is
neutral and a pH of fourteen would be
very alkaline so pH has a very similar
shape of graph to temperature so we can
see that each enzyme will have an
optimum pH for example this one here
could have an optimum pH of around seven
now the reason why the the rate of
reaction is very slow either side is
again the how acid or alkaline it is can
affect the bonds in the active site of
the enzyme and therefore how well the
substrate can be broken down however
different enzymes have
for an optimum ph 'as the an enzyme in
your saliva in your mouth for example
might have the best have an optimum pH
of seven whereas you could have an
enzyme in your stomach that could have
an optimum pH of around one or one or
two so it's a very similar idea to the
temperature graphs for pH but only
remember that different enzymes work
best at different PHS you can even have
one working best at an alkali pH so the
last one we're going to look at is we
are going to look at the effect of
concentration of substrate so remember
concentration basically means how many
of those particles we have within a
particular volume now this one has an
interesting shape it starts to increase
like this but then it reaches a maximum
and levels out like this so why does
this happen let me just draw a little
diagram to show how this works so here
are three enzymes and I'm going to draw
a substrate molecule okay so when we
have a low substrate concentration let's
say if this is shown here because I've
just got one um but there's not going to
be many chance of collisions remember
these are going to be moving around and
the chances of a collision are
relatively low because we only have one
substrate particle molecule here however
if we were to increase the concentration
of substrate molecules as I can show
right here our chances of a collision
between our enzymes active site and our
substrate increases therefore we've got
we've got an increased chance of the
substrate being broken down therefore we
have a faster
rate of reaction so why is it that it
levels out after a while now the reason
for that is this let's say we keep on
increasing the substrate concentration
and keep on going
after a while we can see didn't do that
very well
after oil we can see that all of these
active sites are occupied at any one
time so every single one of these active
sites is brick busy breaking down a
substrate molecule this means that it
doesn't matter how many more substrate
molecules we were introduced it's
working at its maximum rate so all of
the active sites are full so that is how
these three different things affect
enzyme activity the final one remember
was constant substrate concentration
thank you